is this true that you you modeled you
modeled before acting
is that right yeah what kind of modeling
did you do i did stuff for abercrombie
and fitch but
you would never know because none of my
pictures got released
and um they took photos of you and they
never used them yeah
which i thought was unbelievable until
um
my agent emailed and was like why didn't
you ever use her and then they
instead of answering with with any words
or explanation they just sent over the
photos
and it was there was this one part where
they throw us
through us a football and we were on the
beach so they were like play football
this is you and
other girls another yeah other model
boys girls there's like this one picture
where this girl is like just about to
catch this
football in behind her i'm like flared
nostrils red face my hair's crazy
and i'm like mid-air look and at one
point she screamed get her away from me
[Laughter]
yeah it was so you were just they're
modeling and you were really playing
i thought that overnight i just got
really good at football and then i
realized that
they were model footballing and i was
really playing
football so i was like these guys suck
and then they didn't yeah and i ended up
losing now
long run what'd you do for the super
bowl for the super bowl i
had a little party i just had a few
friends over and i normally i always
hate the super bowl i'm like what like
now everybody cares about football and
everybody's like oh the commercials are
the best part and like
you're not having a fun time if
commercials are your favorite part of
anything
right so um so i thought i hated it but
then i understood it it was like five
beers in and i was just like oh my god
and i was totally captivated
five and now you say that about anything
but now i get the like beer and football
thing it was great and then the power
outage
i was freaking out and everybody's like
you this is your dream nobody's watching
the super bowl and i was just like
what's going on sounds like you had a a
blast do you throw a lot of parties are
you someone who throws parties
no well i kind of have to throw parties
at my house because i never leave my
house
so i just have to invite people over i
sound crazy
no so you don't leave here you will not
leave your house is that true
no not right now yeah you just like to
lay low and have people to your house
yeah then i don't have to change my
pants
if i don't have to put a bra on and i
don't have to change my pants
that's fantastic well i'm coming over
[Laughter]
old creepy guys here i did the dance
remember
uh so uh if you throw a party what's it
like is it a restrained part does it get
pretty nutty oh very restrained there's
lots of rules in my house
um no i guess i don't know i mean it's
not really that many people so it can't
get too out of control it was just
it was just a lot of uh drinking i guess
yeah
oh and we watched the puppy bowl you
watched the puppies on the commercials
did anybody see am i the only one
do i go crazy again no no no no puppy
balls
they gave us it's just puppies and then
they have a little camera under the
water bowl
it's genius and then there's again last
time
jennifer this is the beer talking
there's a camera in the bowl
yeah i know i was just getting really
really excited about
this and do you have celebrities over to
your house or are they civilians who's
coming over
no i don't really know many celebrities
yeah mostly just civilians the common
folk
right it's nice to be kind yeah it's so
funny because you can meet
anybody and i thought like you've met uh
well i met sally field
and she we're going to start a carpool
uh to go to all of these because we were
talking about one of these things that
we have to go to and we're like
this is getting so annoying oh my god
and then she and then she was like you
know what we should do and i thought she
was gonna be like we shouldn't go
and then she just goes we should start a
carpool
and i was like that's a great idea yeah
i was like that's not what i thought you
were going to say
but all right i think it'd be great if
all the celebrities going to the award
shows
yeah all the actress nominees we all
just get a giant minivan like
yeah little sunshine band and just show
up to everything together but just like
you pull over
just actresses well not why not we're
not just everybody like we gotta go get
officers
oh really i don't know i just said that
okay
i don't mean it i'd be happy to drive it